what's the deal it's break baby man
check me out at the bootleg Kev podcast
right now man click the link click the
link click the link man let's do it
don't be late
yo bootleg cat podcast man we got a
special guest in here baby don't be late
don't be late man it's the boy brick man
brick baby uh I have to say so I wasn't
following you about a year ago and you
were trying to DM me and I was already
talking to ill will about your music
because he has sent me this may be two
year and a half that's right when you
got out let me know right when you got
out but yeah
but ill will was like sending me
and I sent it off to Nema and Empire you
probably don't even know I did all this
yeah hell no but then I remember like
seeing you pop up on somebody's [__] and
I checked my DMs and you were banging on
me in the DMS dog
I bet keep that energy because I'm like
I didn't see you dming me because I'm
like damn Kim you didn't made it but but
the whole thing was I I ain't gonna lie
I was doing my rap thing and I was like
bro yeah
I'm like yeah but I I I had
our section that's why I ain't been
prevailing in the years before I know
all the people but when they come down
to putting the music out it's like I'm
I'm trying to learn the tricks of the
trade and it's like all right look I'm
trying to put it all in the right hands
and put it out the right way you get
what I'm saying because like you put out
like I have big features on the way out
so I gotta get because you gotta get my
numbers up at the time you get what I'm
saying okay I heard
you have a whole project with gonna yeah
yeah I got a whole project we got now
but the people all right so Lee was
surprised shout out to my guy Lee
Foundation Foundation immediately was
supposed to put the money up for the
project right but it's already recorded
it's all done and all that and it is not
even and this is like two years old it's
clear yeah you're real tight with two
years YSL yeah oh YSL so yeah me and
Ghana specifically like we're closer not
closer than Thug but like we are on the
same level as how I am with Thug like
because Thug grew up with us basically
before when I was in Atlanta in PeeWee
Longway we all grew up from 18 well when
I was 18. so uh
I got that relationship whatever I come
home and he like look I'm a executive
producer project your first project just
like we're gonna say that yeah yeah he's
like that's how you gonna get a bag
that's what he told me it's how you're
gonna go get the bag tell them how much
they could do it and they go and he like
I got you get it up so we do it we
record he's only on three songs of the
project pretty executive producer yeah
and then I had Dirk on the project I got
all type of like I might have to some of
these songs on my phone actually yeah
you do guys
yeah you got you guys up most of the
songs and it was like all right I'm
dropping I'm dropping then I just
dropped and I went through a whole lot
and people wasn't seeing it because it
was off camera like when I dropped not
enough I had a whole rollout I got
distros begging me to finish like like
to keep dropping right but I went
through recently and it just like it
kind of like
it was like ripping the rap up out of me
like and then it's like I'm reaching out
to rap like my rap friends in the middle
of that trying to keep the rap going on
to you know I mean and it's like
everybody not even when I mean my rap
friend not even the ones that's doing
the rapping it's like the producers is
is right the background folks yeah this
dude
me yeah I mean like like that it's just
like the dots ain't connected so I just
said I'm good at so you decided
to just leave rap alone for now for
those months I'm back but I had to yeah
I had to clear my mind because it was
like if it frustrated me anymore while
I'm going through this and like because
what how long were you locked up for
three years uh three and a half the last
time right yeah
because you had the YG record it was
u-y-g-i-a-d yeah and then I had just
dropped with Chris Brown right after
that and then you ended up locked up
yeah so it was like a bad it was
terrible because you obviously get close
with Chris Brown from that kidding tour
with fetty WAP right yeah well no I was
cool with Chris
by the way that tour just right was it
yeah it was fetty WAP it was fetty WAP
demigos
yeah Tiana Taylor I just was talking
about that yeah it was crazy uh French
Montana French was on it yeah because
French was he was coming out with Chris
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
actually that tour might have
ended our friendship more than you and
Chris's yeah oh wow
I have no idea that's when he was like
running around with like every blood in
L.A on tour yeah man instead everybody
was there what was that guy's name kid
red kid red yeah yeah so I don't know
what the [__] happened yeah Manish was
opening the tour yeah Compton Menace was
the first guy to open the face it was
the first dude yeah yeah it went Compton
Tiana and it went the Migos it was a
very random tour and it was a whole lot
of controversy behind that line who was
opening whoa because I remember Kid Ink
went on after the Migos and at that time
I was like I don't know
Omarion went on after Kid Ink and it
didn't make sense no no no did he go on
I think Omarion went on after Kid Ink
there was something involving ink where
it just Omarion with oh no kid ink was
right behind Chris Chris oh so did
Omarion think he should be yeah he got
over that because of the hits or
whatever the case was but Omarion was at
the half I think he wasn't really
tripping tripping like I don't want to
piss nothing that's what it was because
I remember hearing about it all right so
this I went it went uh
I think he had to go before fetty WAP
he had to go before fetty WAP he like
fetty WAP knew and I wasn't doing Chris
like this when when they was going on
tour with us did ink go on after fetty
wiper before
he went on after fetty that's who I'm
thinking there's just no way at that
time yeah yeah it was it was a big homie
move you kind of know at that time
Chris Brown still Chris Brown one of the
greatest entertainers we've ever had
lived but I was on the radio side giving
away tickets to that that tour
and listeners were calling in and they
weren't saying I want Chris Brown
tickets they were saying I want fetty
WAP tickets because that was when fetty
WAP was it was a bit and it was fetty
WAP he's so humble he was paying his
respect he didn't even yeah because he
just was like like I think people
understand the 2014-15 fetty WAP run he
was crazy that's what I'm like you go
out there and when he goes out there
you're gonna hear everybody yeah baby oh
my God he was doing the Hot 100 Fest on
his days off that's what that's what
type of a tour he run he was having like
you hear what I said he was doing the
Billboard Hot 100 concerts and [__] like
his one arms were crazy so you obviously
you grew up out here in LA right for
people who but but you you how did you
end up in Atlanta uh College okay so
where'd you go Clark Atlanta okay so we
know where you're from obviously because
you say it all the time oh see except
I'd like to point out too that the first
time that you and it was you [__] Mack
and was it Sharp
yeah when he came on oh my God oh my God
it was classic bro I was just so wildly
entertained by like the on hood on 6-0
and like yo homie guys Papa's in prison
you guys are just mentioning people's
names I'm just like this is the most
wild ganged out
but see people don't see that side of me
because I switch it up but like people
that I've been ganging with that's like
our our lingo that's like no I I mean
and that's why it was just and it was so
funny because like you were just here
like like the way like [__] back was
talking about like catching fades in
prison and you're like you know six oh
he got hands like I saw him in county or
whatever it's like Jesus Christ yeah we
was living cause like we was in stores
like that before like now we go to jail
we would be like oh they're like stores
like the police know you celebrity so
they try to put you away because you
might have an influence or people might
want to get at you just to show off type
[__] whatever you can't really Escape it
I mean I'll probably sign a waiver they
probably end up snatching me up to take
me up there anyway yeah I'm saying it'll
be too much controversy with me or like
I mean yeah so uh
we was on the main line we really was
thugging like you know what I'm saying
we eating with we fighting we doing
everything together yeah in the county
they always say that county is like the
worst place yes the worst
and so let me get this straight because
you don't go outside every day right you
don't have a regular program the food
and in County isn't the LA politics are
still intact as to where if you go to
prison the politics swish a little yeah
so in County you squabble your enemies
like if you see somebody who's a like an
OP or whatever yeah yeah you guys end up
in prison together y'all might be
together yeah because if you're a [__]
you're a [__] of blood you all gonna be
together it ain't just no because it's a
race it's a race thing in prison right
yeah it's really a respect thing like if
somebody disrespects you then you got
all all action at the fade stabbing
whatever but if everybody keep it
respectful is yes everybody's a gang
member you know it's like it's gonna be
people from every Hood so if you're
gonna keep tripping on every year
you're gonna die yeah yeah I felt really
bad like when I saw money sign sway pass
away man in there I was like [__] like
see I just found out he was a
non-affiliate though that's what I'm
saying like he seemed like he was just a
good kid who just ended up getting
locked up yeah so what it was when they
put that pressure on him he was standing
he was standing on business and it's
like it's nobody there to back him
because he's not from a gang so they
know he got money and they thinking that
he's showing off just because he's a
rapper they the only thing they have
left to do is to do some [__] like that
instead of embracing me I mean like be
happy yeah I mean because I'm assuming
he was in general population yeah he was
he was is it because I always say like
dude if I ever God forbid had to go to
like
County Jail I'm figuring out a way to go
to [__] PC I'm like slapping
put me in the hole pause
I don't want to be around nobody yeah
they gonna love you man it's good that
ain't that I went to jail I went to jail
once for one night
and somehow while being there
bro like I'm like in the holding cells
in Arizona
[__] six dudes just throughout the
day just walk by and recognize me and
I'm like
they're like why are you here and I'm
like oh no
I thought you were in a world where
nobody knew kid everybody knows I'm
using my sneaker as a pillow yeah at
your lowest with a little tissue roll on
top of it toilet paper
I didn't eat any of the food hell no I
was like I don't want to take a [__]
you're not you're not doing none of that
for at least three four days especially
your first time like come on man but
yeah with like you're famous though so
you go high power
me high power is like we're Suge Knight
and everybody was that okay okay that's
what we're talking about trying to go to
jail that's where a Soulja Boy was that
you you you're in like a one-man sale
that's all yeah give me the one man yeah
but I don't want to go yeah nah let's
point that out I'm not going I don't
either that's what I'm like yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm not going back either
that's out yeah I mean so you were in
college
um you while you're in Atlanta you end
up linking with everybody out there is
doing doing you know yeah doing what
they doing shout out to PeeWee who's a
legend yeah man shout out a long way man
one of the most Mister don't speak he
won't talk he don't do interviews or
nothing I mean he did the blad one but
it was a you know yeah he answered
questions the right way and now yeah
yeah yeah now nobody would interview
because I was trying to no not not will
interview but nobody wants like desire
to say because you're not gonna get that
none of them know it we'll just talk
about like you know food or something or
yeah food videos
yeah we gotta stop the interview real
quick and tell you about our folks at my
bookie man look my bookie NFL season is
approaching and you know what they just
added that I love is that early cash out
let's say you got a ticket and it's
looking great you can cash out early on
that ticket all right I love it all
right plus of course my bookie's got the
full casino going down and if you sign
up right now using the promo code
bootleg they will give you that first
deposit bonus up to a thousand
all right so head over to my bookie ASAP
um look we're at uh NFL coming there's
baseball you can gamble on right now and
of course the full service casino
blackjack with the real dealer uh
roulette craps whatever you're into slot
machines you could do it and cash out
right on my bookie all right all you got
to do is sign up with that new promo
code bootleg when you sign up
trust me when I say it's a new account
they're gonna get you that uh first
deposit bonus all right so go to uh
mybookie right now use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account also got to give a big shout out
to the family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview yo it's
crazy because you were you were around
during this era because like I just
think of like some of these guys who
like
in theory shouldn't be
hanging out with gang members you know
yeah but then like you you guys moved to
LA and then all of a sudden they're like
Affiliated as soon as and it's like
as soon as they get here and I don't
know how much of that is like Mutual or
how much of it is like but I kind of
need to have somebody around Bow Wow
jumping off the porch was crazy to me
that was one of the biggest like Soulja
Boy always even but even like even like
the Chris Brown [__] like Chris Brown's
a child star yeah he first came out when
he was 16 years old his mom was this man
living here for that long like he'd been
here since he was 18. that's what I'm
saying something like Dan you're like I
don't understand what happened there
like is it these are just his friends or
did he want to get down or and then you
know I mean some people like always
wanted to be in the streets and and then
like when we were kids
you it is a such thing as being off the
porch before 16 like where I'm from of
course like I've been like around this
[__] no no but we're talking about
people who like had it Platinum songs
when they were children yeah like but at
what time when when was this first
Platinum hit though like when was the
first time
it was when he was 16 with juelz's here
all right so you got to think I met
Chris Brown at a dinner gotta think 11
12 13 14 when you learning how to be bad
and all that [__] what are you looking
up to here VA they might have a blood
gang in VA that then he moves to La I
know the first time I met Chris Brown I
was an intern at a radio station and we
had this big label dinner in Phoenix
and his mom would not let him order soda
so he oh uh he ordered a chocolate milk
oh wow this was like
so he did a radio show for us and he was
over 60. no yeah so it's crazy let me
tell you the lineup so he opened it's a
nightclub show it's probably like 1200
people it's a radio event and it's a
concert
the closer was Ray J because he had one
wish wow the mid person was well ready
Ricky what oh yeah and the opener was
[__] Chris Brown bro but see that's
what uh Omarion was saying he was like
when he was getting on we was letting
him come perform we wasn't pushing him
to the back of the concert
but Omarion is like okay you got
groceries out hey yeah that's even the
name of the song right but that people
know what is the name supposed to be
supposed to be yeah yeah that's what I'm
like so you had that out and you was
feeling it but he had like another song
that took off somehow remember what was
it yeah like heart uh ice spot he had
some other records oh I'm talking about
right around that time yeah I don't
remember yeah it was another one though
but at that time but Kid Ink's got like
going back to back with the
[__] Just Hits yeah he's crazy
back to back a little for a second I was
gonna say like um so you end up in
Atlanta
where do you end up
how did College end how many years did
you end up doing and did you like did
you like what what would your college
Journey end like pretty early or
wait say it one more time your college
Journey like where did it end at like
how many years yeah super early
uh it is
finals week first first uh finals week
of second semester that's where mine was
yeah yeah actually I finished the first
semester and I don't think I ever went
again yeah so I it was finals week
second semester I got caught with with
the pack oh yeah I got caught with the
pack okay I'm sure at that time you're
probably bringing La [__] over
what we going crazy what it was going
crazy but yeah duh shout out uh the girl
who told on me oh so you got Snapchat
yeah
that would have happened uh you would
have finished College
definitely I probably would it nah yeah
I would have finished College you could
have a different life no because I was
just thinking like what else I had going
on because I wanted to say something
else but it was like
right then
all the people I was rotating with
because when I got to college I found
out it was a gang that just [__]
selling drugs and going to class like if
you could go to class and keep this
money on Campus because it was like a
black school like white school is still
going on people still serving these
people said yeah you get what I'm saying
but there's an actor yeah so if you're a
adderall dealer in [__] College
you're running it you're going crazy
yeah back then too like that was the
first time I ever heard of Adderalls
when I got the cops yeah because people
would take that [__] to study to study
and all that [__] I'm like what the [__]
they like it's the study pill take one
I'm like they make you seem like there's
no meth in there
that's crazy what were you uh what were
your aspirations in terms of like what
you were trying to like study or major
in uh criminal justice oh wow
I hadn't really figured it out I wanted
to I I wanted to be a lawyer but I knew
I wasn't going to want to do that much
schooling you get what I'm saying I
probably was gonna end up doing like
real estate and all that [__] with my
Mom apparently but yeah yeah but I was
going I because they was like you could
be a probation officer you could be this
you could imagine you would have had a
probation officer yeah juvenile I'm like
they're not gonna accept me as no type
of office they probably wouldn't yeah
then I'm like I don't want to be a
lawyer yeah because I just I was just
lazy at that point I was playing
basketball still like
going through the fact that I'm 5'8 and
I'm not going to the league so [__]
basketball yeah you being Isaiah Thomas
over here yeah you get what I'm saying
I'm like man that's over with you at
your school
at Clark yeah I have walked on
we uh cause I I had just transferred
back from a basketball Prep School in
Mississippi to my high school oh [__] in
California you were in the South yeah no
I I had they had they made me go I don't
know because my PR is supposed to be
pulling up my back can I yeah
yo
it's a camel non-filter but if you
if they don't got them just come on it's
called camel non-filter it's the little
it's the small package brown right all
brown pack yeah it's the soft pack
it's a Turkish blend on it because it
don't say non-filtered on there say
camel's Turkish blend
all right
but you can't call me back bro
I'ma just put it on look at the [__]
thumbnail
already got it ready to go oh yeah all
right what were we talking about uh
college no we were talking about um so
you said you were playing basketball in
Mississippi oh yeah yeah transferred yes
to back okay okay so I transferred back
to my school in California and
um
they will be ineligible as a legal
transfer from Mississippi because they
was like
it was The Scouting thing going on with
Amir Johnson Gabriel Pruitt Aaron to
follow like everybody that went to like
different schools and they was uh
because they always ask Centennial and
then they end up going to Westchester
and they was going to different schools
so the CIF had put like a band on us
like transferring schools you had to sit
out a year like he was in college once
you transferred so I transferred back to
the school that I came from before I was
having behavioral problems so they sent
me off I kept going to jail and doing
[__] like that in Mississippi no
in Cali they force you to leave yeah no
mama yeah my mom like uh [__] you go out
here I'll make sure you get a car when
you come back like you know what I'm
saying she kind of bright kind of like
going to Mississippi play basketball
today yeah boom I made sure I got kicked
out immediately so as I got out there
like she got me I'm like don't trip I'm
smoking weed on campus I'm I painted a
[__] goat into a zebra
we took the paint down today how long
did you live there uh like six months
Mississippi wow it was crazy but it was
a co-ed school first [__] yeah it was
[__] there so it was like college
before college that school actually made
me want to go to college oh fine because
I'm like damn I wasn't at home I'm like
and it was [__] I'm like I gotta go
to school anyway right I'm like [__] I
should have
but then I'm like I ain't in L.A right
you know what I'm saying like if this
school could exist in L.A somewhere I'd
be at school it'll be lit what I just
need to get back to my people like yeah
I'm saying that especially when I was in
high school everybody having fun I'm
calling in it's like [__]
yeah yeah so uh
yeah I transferred there so when I end
up going 12th grade I don't have too
many
like tapes and all that [__] so I'm
really not going to [__] know D1 this
is my like right showing like you're
real yeah you get upset so I ended up
working out the whole year with the team
still we end up winning the state
championship whatever and I [__] go
to Clark because that's the only school
that I applied for like I I was no FAMU
and Clark but Clark's to hpcu yeah yeah
okay yeah so I was only going there
because my sister lived by Clark right
I'm like the only way I'm going to
college if I go to Clark I want to go to
be near your family yeah no it ain't
even that I want to go to Atlanta in
Atlanta yeah mind you I have my sister
telling me like are you making music at
the time no no no no no no I wasn't even
thinking about it was like Atlantis yeah
yeah we used to like pop fields and
freestyle I always can rap like but I
never ever like was writing raps right
you never like recording yourself you
were just [__] around yeah I [__]
around I probably record like
if everybody right there like if I pull
up on the rapper homie session and I'll
be like let me try to yeah I mean but I
never took rap like it was just
something like I mean like I never
accumulated CDs right or nothing like
that bro so
move on I get kicked out from right
there yeah when I get kicked out well
mind you I already know Big Meech and
all that when I got there not bit I keep
saying big me I knew Big Meech but I
knew the BMS soon as I got there I was
with big mess you get what I'm saying so
we was moving around just before Mech
got locked up yeah for sure and uh we
was moving around rotating so my name
was already like oh that's a little dude
that'd be with them so after I got
kicked out of college I'm just outside
now yeah and I'm like I'm not going back
to L.A it's too much money out here yeah
and PeeWee ended up getting out of
prison and then I'm like yeah I mean
that's like my brother-in-law so wait
peewee's your brother-in-law yeah my so
his bro
his brother was [__] with my sister
that lives in Atlanta yeah so you
already had like yeah yeah are they
still together nah okay they broke up
they was together for like years years
like yeah I mean that's it just so you
like people was like Family Guy yeah so
it's like [__] all right boom what we
gonna do he came home from jail he just
like me right like [__] it yeah I mean
we should start [__] around rapping
doing what we was doing crazy that's how
it started because it was PeeWee like
like I think I kind of started to hear
about Peewee and like
this was like oh wait I was gonna say
like 2012.
so like that was because that was the
Gucci yeah the NPA 10-17 [__] yeah yeah
he was dope man I feel like he doesn't
get enough love or props when it comes
to like PBA and his social is he
supposed to be man him and scooter I
feel like are just [__] they just
they're like for whatever reason just
Street Legends okay snap out of the
street legend yeah peewee's dope man
yeah so you end up working with peewee
how does this because I met you through
Kid Ink so how do you become because
were you like bat gang essentially yeah
so how do you end up working with ink
because you were like his shadow so you
guys are related so you and ink are
related I didn't know that I just know
how Sierra related oh okay I see is my
real cousin his wife yeah yeah shout out
to his wife by the way I'm so happy that
we have a hip-hop couple that's [__]
locked in still together they've been
together since high school that [__] is
like yeah that ain't going nowhere oh my
God they are locked in okay yeah I
always so I didn't know that you were
related to his wife who's a sweetheart
shout out to her she's amazing
um I always just assumed that like you
were just like a artist that he [__]
with that was in town and like it also
probably didn't hurt that you were like
yeah brick baby back there right so when
you guys are on the road I'm like well
he's kind of got a street guy on the
crew he was understanding to play yeah
yeah or not that's that's family so it
was just like yeah I was [__] up he
like man come on let me help you out
let's go because I he taught me how to
like like rap and put that [__] together
he used to really record me while I was
trying no he's so good at like so like
people don't understand he's a great
producer he's a great engineer and he's
just like yeah he understands like the
musicality of like song structure and
like melody in such a crazy way and
that's why he can't make he can't go to
making dumb down songs right like he if
you know baby it's not in them yeah it's
like making music that's not making
music but like I even think like the
first record that like really went to
radio was time of your life which is
like such a crazy record when you hear
you're just like this song could pop at
any any it wherever you are Timeless
yeah even even hell and back it it
creeped on everybody like Helen Back
wasn't even like the [__] song that
was picked to hit the radio is that the
one that MGK was on
MGK record that went uh Platinum back
out of nowhere I remember it will post
it but it's crazy to see like so I don't
know
so that whole that whole era like you
end up working with ink what what at
what point in time was this was this
prior to him really kind of commercially
having his moment because I remember he
was doing like
him and
I remember
when ink came to Phoenix early on it was
him and either Dizzy Wright or Hopsin
dizzy right it was dizzy and Phoenix it
was dizzy yep and I remember the show
sold out but everybody was there to see
Kid Ink and my boy was there and he was
sending me pictures like oh the [__]
this kid ain't dude is like and I'd
heard of him but I had always when I
when I heard his name and I saw he was a
guy with a lot of tattoos I was like oh
yeah of course there's a guy named Kid
Ink with a lot of tattoos because there
was another guy that was like that ink
monster yes and I was like yeah of
course they used to always they used to
always confuse but then you'd hear
kidding some music and you'd be like oh
this is
crazy yeah so you think that comes from
understanding music what year did you
guys have feel like what year did you
officially start rolling with him and
learning music from him and doing all
that
after I got shot in the neck for sure
well right before I got shot in the neck
like 2009 oh so early yeah
I bet that was what you said when I
started doing the music but I've been
supporting them since like 2000 like
eight like right when he as soon as he
start doing the rap thing uh because
like he was doing the producers you know
producers are quiet you don't know where
he was making beats for people yeah but
you don't know like Sean Kingston and
like yeah and Diddy and all type of
different people nip okay so we're
talking about Kid Ink um
obviously uh would you say Inc was kind
of like
your real real introduction into like
that was my big break into the industry
I mean you get to see the world right
well well maybe not the world yeah no
the world well not Canada though well I
can't go to Canada I was just saying
that's the only place you can't see is
Canada right Australia can't go to
Australia
but you were able to go to Europe you
were able to go to some of those like
crazy European tours or whatever BMV
yeah we're opening for one of those
tours yeah yeah over there yeah but I
went multiple times like I've been
overseas so many times with him it was
Unreal I was starting to feel like I
wasn't from America anymore for a second
that shit's crazy because we were out
there 90 days at a time I feel like once
a year he'd go on one of those runs
right here like for sure he got running
the bag up yeah right before Christmas
did you ever do Dubai with him
um I never did Dubai with him okay never
did Dubai with him because once divides
start coming around I start having like
legal issues to where I couldn't travel
at all what what ended up being the
reason why you had to go sit down for
three and a half years uh
foreign
so
we were still at jackets man now I just
play and I might as well just say it
because every time I try to [__]
explain myself it sounds terrible that I
was even with a dude that was still some
jackets like but what happened I went to
The Vape Store
I had an altercation with somebody at
the vape store yeah Fairfax but it was
like about something else it was the
manager that did something to one of my
people outside of the workplace I told
him to come outside we chopping it up it
gets heated
the dude that I'm with sneaks off into
the store because everybody's [__]
not paying attention he goes into the
[__] storage room and steals like
eight Bape jackets it comes running out
knocks over a [__] uh
ladder
so it alerts everybody and then they
start fighting them and [__] and all
that and like I'm breaking up the fight
um telling them what the [__] are you
doing stealing like yeah I'm saying like
but there's no audio on the camera I'm
like yelling at him on the camera the
whole time yeah
they get off of them whatever the case
is
and uh
he ends up leaving with me so they say
that I'm a part of the crime because I
left with him but I was getting I really
was did he like own up and be like no it
was on me no no he did some oh [__] and
he told him like he got like three photo
dudes life over that [__] too not over
that robbery like him fighting that case
and trying to get himself out of it he
told on some murders
Jesus
that's crazy bro this is crazy such like
a it's like one of my day when things I
didn't even know you had that in you my
boy it's crazy as he goes it's such a
weird moment to like get caught on
camera it's just such a
it's like a flash in a pan incident
where you're like this [__] is not like
a normal dub caught a case over that
[__] that was my uh crybee that stuffed
up yeah that's what's my boy that's why
I codified it wow because he picked up a
jacket off the ground because the
jackets flew everywhere it was everybody
but he grabbed the jacket but they got
his license plate number when he grabbed
the jacket so they were just like I
don't know because of the fight and the
damages that were done to the employees
that ran up like they I feel like we
should have filed a lawsuit on them
because like I mean in L.A it could have
worked yeah because like are you allowed
to chase somebody out the store and
fight them over in the inventory I know
it says in the rule book you guys
probably give it up you guys probably
called the police could have shoot him
which is crazy but you could yeah that's
what I'm saying like I I know the law
but I was in jail so it was no way I
could yeah I mean because it's like bro
that can't be in you guys's handbook to
chase people lost prevention handbook
because it's like let them go and call
the police you're not supposed to do
anything physical
yeah I mean so it is what it is and they
they wanted me to tell on these same
murders
you get what I'm saying so they bet your
boy did he hit that my boy was telling
though he was telling them on some
murder so they kept like oh you're
co-defendant tell me you told us that
you know something man I don't know
nothing yeah I don't yeah I mean like so
that's why it was prolonged and Covey
came around made my case stretch even
longer like you know what I'm saying and
I ended up getting out with time sir
but they charged us with robbery Jesus
so you're in were you incarcerated were
you incarcerated when it passed
what was that environment like
like how was that received in jail like
what was the the mood like in there
because man I I was on the radio the day
it was the Sunday he passed
and I could and I had a really good
relationship with nip you know
and I couldn't even tell you man I've
never experienced anything like being in
La it's div day today
this is his birthday yeah so it's their
day today I just I've never experienced
like Kobe died and like and listen man
I've shed a tear for Kobe too but it was
not like when Nick died that [__] would
help me [__] me up too but when nip
passed it you could like bro I've never
seen like a city heartbroken like that
the jail like I said I never see that
they get [__] that's supposed to hate
the hood they crying the enemy's crying
no matter if they try to act hard like
[__] nip at the end of the day everybody
[__] with Nipsey yeah be like in this
show like the whole the south side is
for sure you know they love Nipsey yeah
yeah yeah I mean uh they was [__] up
about it everybody was [__] up like it
was crazy because I'm like
because uh op told me he like hey bro
call in to see they say nip just got
killed through Kershaw sauce and I'm
like man stop playing with me he like he
like but this my boy though I'm like why
are you why is you playing with my own
boy like no I'm serious and I he like
you could see like a tear trickling down
I'm like
what the [__] I get to the phone I'm
like hey they like yeah I'm like man
what the [__] look like he's like uh
call right back we about to tell you
what happened we gonna tell you who it
was
I called back
and they tell me like they figure out
how to tell me when they tell me I'm
like
what the [__] is going on out there like
how the [__] did he where did he even
come from how did they get into it like
you know what I'm saying like that [__]
was crazy bro did you know uh Eric
Holder at all like did you have any sort
of like what you used to call dude you
didn't always call me brick baby right
chitty [__] yeah so I remember I
remember having that conversation with
ill will like this guy's got to change
his name because he's never I can't say
his name on the radio you're the one
that made me change my name you don't
know that because it was it was [__] was
it [__] baby or shitty baby it was break
baby [__] truck that's what it was yeah
yeah yeah yeah I just remember being
like bro I can't say his name on the
radio I can't play his music but you
know my street name is shitty okay yeah
so so you knew Eric yeah I'm a little
shitty so you're doing pretty well yeah
damn yeah yeah that [__] is crazy yeah I
I I know him knowing so when you found
out it was him [__] me up it was like
God damn like what the [__] is going on
like yeah I mean
it's like
that [__] just was like what the [__]
like
it took me from crying to like no tears
because it's like
what the [__] did this like what the
[__] going on out there like you know I
mean I can't ask nobody everybody else
here been in jail yeah man I can't ask
nobody what's going on how what's the
backstory or nothing so I just know this
and I know that that shit's crazy man
do you think it was like
some [__] that because I feel like it it
came off like he was obviously
I don't know if it was like it just came
off like like some like some heartless
[__] or some [__] that like maybe like a
crackhead or a dope fiend type thing
would do like you hear so many different
things though yeah it was definitely of
like meth and all type of other like
yeah I mean whatever you know yeah
unless you live it like that whatever
come across your plate so uh
he was he was definitely off drugs and
uh I don't know I wasn't there for the
conversation yeah I mean so I always
speculation I can't tell you what was
said what was not but obviously it was
something that said heavy on his brain
and and he doubled back and did whatever
he he did yeah I said well he's already
accused I mean got found guilty but he
killed him
over pondering too much thinking too
much over something where it's like this
is a rumor in the hood if you know that
you didn't do it then leave I mean like
yeah you didn't do nothing right there
what the [__] did you double but now
your life's over yeah you just double
your life's overhead and you know that
your your boy who
this your brother me you know I [__]
with this dude on a day to day like this
my dude like you get what I'm saying
like you you you take yourself away from
everybody that you ain't thinking about
it like you could have double back and
[__]
like why would you throw your life away
on camera and and you got to be on drugs
you know what I'm saying like you know
you know you're not getting away with
this you out here with your shirt off
you doing all this [__] like you can't
be thinking the right way and tons of
people are standing there who aren't him
like you know it was just it was just it
to me it was like one of the more and
like I didn't you know it just feels
like I'm ready to go out type [__] yeah
like some suicide missions yeah that's
what it was like I'm ready to go out
[__] it that's the last thing I'm gonna
hear about some snitches like that I I
don't know I don't get it it's crazy
yeah I mean like recipes nift though
yeah he was a great guy man he was an
amazing guy
um I was gonna say for you like uh
you've gotten into this new space where
your immediate personality right yeah so
it's different
um for you I'm sure being on camera all
day yeah way different
um have you
because you obviously represent what you
represent and you also are on camera
every day so have you
like what has been the adjustment for
you to be like okay I have to still be
who I am but I also want to be a
professional and grow within this new
world that I'm getting into because at
the end of the day
you see that there is a very lucrative
is is go that the content right yeah I
mean you see A.D and and and Tyrell left
and they're doing well yeah you know I
know Adam doesn't want that yeah but
they're doing well they think yeah so
it's like there's obviously like this is
like a new a new frontier for you so
like how are you adjusting
being you unapologetically and represent
what you represent while also
being a professional because I think you
did it pretty well in the Snoopy badass
thing that I saw yeah well I'm
dedicating all my time to this like
is a a certain point you gotta
hit a grow growth spurt and understand
the growth spurt like sometimes people
grow and they don't understand it like I
mean or like we go through things like
I literally damn near lost it all this
year and got it back
off of just doing this you get what I'm
saying when the whole time I've been out
here scrambling trying to figure out all
right decide this I'm trying to figure
out the music yeah yeah like no I'm
talking about the streets yeah yeah but
but the music too you hear what I'm
saying like it's just like you play 150
and one foot out no that's what I want
to do and this is what I want to do but
you not giving
they sit on the side they could
almost pay you quadruple or a hundred
times more depending on how much work
you put in you're not giving this no
attention so sometimes it got to be like
took from out your face so you can focus
on one thing and and like when you see
that
you kind of like chosen for this space
and people kind of [__] with you in this
space and they're like yeah I mean if
you'll be a fool not to capitalize off
of what you got going on and not just
give it y'all yeah I would say like
you've done a really good job like I
always I I told this to Adam I was like
what I like about brick baby he's you're
like a really measured guy
on camera yeah yeah like I'm I'm too
calm like him yelling and just agreeing
with I told him what was not about to
happen in the interview who wins out of
that right because
I think like a lot of people would be
like you know because when I when I when
that's why I I told Adam the same [__] I
was like bro brick baby's like very
naturally like I think I text you too
like yo you're really good at this [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah you did you know
like I think I would like to see you
just do more like one-on-one [__] yeah
that's what I that's what I'm uh
that's why I'm at no jumper though
because I'm learning from somebody
that's like one of the best like and I
you can say what you want but like when
you line up the best podcasters and I'm
learning from some of it one of the top
dogs in the broadcast game and it's like
I don't know how to like if I just jump
on and just if the break baby from when
I started going viral and seeing the
internet was [__] with me and all
that [__]
if I was to just start asking somebody
questions on camera
I wouldn't have it written there I
wouldn't be I would just be having the
conversation and I wouldn't know which
way to swing [__] into you give it up I
think you just gotta learn it's just
like a combo it's like yeah yeah no it's
a convo but
what type of combo because I could have
any type of difference
which is hilarious you get what I'm
saying yes so it's like I gotta for me
it takes me to separate and learn how to
articulate just just be on one type of
time you know what I'm saying so once I
get myself together there's nothing you
could tell me like we sitting right here
had you want to do anything else I don't
even got it yet we don't gotta yell you
just get to it ain't no point to doing
all the Barking right like it ain't no
point of that and I also think like it's
important to understand like hey man
we're we're grown now like we already
like if you you've sat down you've done
everything you need to do at what point
in time do you what do you have to prove
to anybody like I'd rather
you know they're gonna test you they're
gonna test you as as a black in the
streets or just saying you from the
streets they're gonna test you to the
day you die 100 I I've ever for the
blacks like other people yeah I grow up
and not like that but [__]
understands like we're grown man it's
interesting because it's almost like
people get angry at you if you're mature
if you mature past the the the obvious
immaturity that
the street shade if you think about it
is extremely it's like an immature
lifestyle right you're supposed to be
extremely reactive to things that Mo
normal people wouldn't be reactive to
and it's like yo if I already got
through that part of my life and I'm
still here and I don't know yo I'm I'm
growing up now like like yeah what the
[__] is it and it's like I saw people
giving Jeezy [__] because like he was
like the bigger man with the Gucci [__]
I don't know man Jesus Jeezy sold out
I'm like what did you want Jeezy to do
that you you want Jeezy to not wear a
suit and go do a podcast and write a
book and like it's like you you know I
mean
he went over whatever he was gonna do
but at the end of the day what club
supposed to fight the [__] for the
world right there and yeah she's come
out and said he kind of regretted how he
handled that yeah yeah so it's like at
the end of the day because Gucci feel
like a kid his girl told him you you
kind of yeah I mean that's when when you
had that conversation with your wife and
they were like hey that was kind of
childish like yeah damn you think so
like yeah I mean like because
that [__] ain't 25 28 no more like it
ain't yeah I mean [__] ain't even that
[__] ain't even it doesn't add up like
you want me to keep on standing outside
either selling drugs or holding guns
whatever the case is you know what I'm
saying like because you're not gonna be
there and don't be protected whatever it
is at 35 and keep going to jail making
and also rather than me starting a
career yeah and doing what the [__] I'm
doing the elevating like yeah I'm gonna
choose that over anything right yeah
because at the end of the day who are
who are you to your children like yeah
yeah for real who are you to your kids
that's all you should worry about like
who are you to your children as long as
you taking like these are people that
and not all of them but the people that
they want us to to be like are you going
to jail you missing out on your kids
like it's no way that you're taking care
of your kids to your full possible like
your capability if you incarcerated if
you on parole all the time if you got to
check in here you can't go here you
can't take them to this tournament out
here you can't do this you get what I'm
saying it's so many restrictions that
the streets put in your life like and I
I got uh that out my mind song where I
say I'm one foot in the game one foot
out like I'm thinking about going all in
in the blind like going legit and been
crossing my mind like I I I was just
talking about me just being in the
streets and like [__] I said the
streets Hold Me Back have been blocking
my shine like you get what I'm saying
like at the end of the day
everything that comes to the end comes
to the end because of the street ties
and the [__] never gave the
legal Lane a shot ever you get what I'm
saying and and you have an opportunity
to give it a real shot so why can't a
[__] put everything into it like I put
everything into the streets because
guess what if you're one foot in one
foot out that's just gonna follow you to
wherever you're trying to get the legal
[__] together that's what I'm trying to
tell you so it's like you gotta it's not
bounce out the streets or oh disconnect
from oh I'm not from here no more or
whatever it's like I'm forever gonna be
who I am yeah you get what I'm saying
but that [__] can't control
a hundred percent of my day no more 100
like every everybody's opinion it can't
like I'm a grown-ass man you could talk
to them kids like that and try to get
them together I didn't already went
tested and approved and been through all
that little [__] right there you're not
about to try to run me through the
ringer like [__] yeah I mean
I'm not even going for that I don't even
respond like [__] man you know you
can't do that I was gonna say I saw what
I really thought was dope was um and I
told him this at the time one of the
early interviews he wrote it on no
jumper was the interview J Stone yeah
which was like a big deal for people
don't know from La like the two gangs
are obviously not friendly right
um would you ever interview somebody
from that side just to try to show
people what's you know yeah yeah well
uh
I wouldn't mind interviewing somebody
from that side they already know me they
know how I'm coming right like me and
Trail and nitty and all them we've been
homies for years I wouldn't mind having
nitty on and yeah or or going on with
Trail or whatever and just sitting down
and talking
everybody know that we cool we both say
it all the time I mean like we both shot
each other out like all the [__] that's
going on with what they got going though
it's funny to me and yeah I mean I'm
right with no jumper cause I'm over
there and content purposes yeah I mean
all I see it is content competition I
don't see nothing physically ever
happening
I'm like I make jokes from time to time
when they make jokes like [__] no jumper
I make a joke too but they know I'm
making jokes like you get what I'm
saying and I hate to water it down like
that but you know I I just two gang
members beef over Summers of [__] we
already enemies it could have been
beefing if we was because we're gonna be
there's other like yeah
exactly exactly have you had to real
like I gotta ask you this because there
was a couple of times like where I know
ad like kind of had some off camera
combos with Adam about certain [__] have
you because Adam is charged up right now
now he went in on you on his IG story
today he went crazy today he went crazy
and he was like I don't know if it's the
creatine do you ever feel like you gotta
kind of like have you or or would you
ever like if you think he's getting a
little playing like crossing the line a
little because you know at the end of
the day A.D pun t-rell these guys are
like real dudes you know what I'm saying
and where and like you said outside of
the content space you're friendly with
these guys yeah
would you ever like have that like has
it gotten to the point apparently if it
hasn't yet if you haven't had the talk
but would you ever like pull out into
the side and be like
hey man like
you're playing with fire at this point
because I just saw the DMS with Heather
and I was like oh don't put her DMS
online that's not nice this is the thing
he feel like they get to say whatever
they want to say and he got to sit back
and listen well and he has been quiet
for a long time and so he just like [__]
it like like [__] want to keep
on doing it and just I mean he he was
calling them the no jumper react I saw
the the no reaction page well you're
right I do feel like for a very long
time he kind of like was not
acknowledging it yeah so if he gets
something off his chest it's like [__]
it like what are we gonna do here like I
mean like because
he feels like the people who are doing
this for Content purposes or whatever
they doing they are the people that
really walked away right and they really
didn't get fired you get what I'm saying
like it was a whole lot behind what
really went on so he like all right
y'all play victim enough but now every
day like you're upset because I'm not
telling my side of the story now he's
telling his side story he's going wild
he's going down he's going up what you
call it hang out with your hangout
that's what he's doing right now I was
gonna say for you like I think like
there's a lot of misconceptions about
Adam but I think one of the main things
that people will talk about is how like
for whatever reason he's extremely
infatuated with gang culture yeah and if
you look at the previous regime of
co-hosts and the new regime of co-hosts
is scripts yeah yeah he [__] with the
Crips I guess hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
Odd Socks baby shout out to Odd Socks
man the most comfortable socks in the
world Listen they got all the licenses
if you love chips you know what I'm
saying they got the Funyuns they got the
goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather was double by Odd
Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet they also just
introduce their draws that's right we
got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsocksofficial.com right
now use that promo code bootleg and
you'll save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction or maybe your thing
ain't thanging like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you asking me does
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking me your girl will be thinking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview
The Narrative about Adam is like hey
he's infatuated with you know black
violence gang culture this that and the
fourth but then like you'll realize like
Adam I think it's just really like a
very curious dude who's just like a true
content creator so like you know these
are the people he's around and what like
I don't feel like he like purposely
sought brick baby out because you were a
[__]
who you say what no add I'm to my Adam
oh he's about the misperceptions of Adam
oh yeah nah no me and me and me and Adam
been cool since like
2015. because I think people are like yo
okay ADT left and he just went and got
more Crips but me and dub like dub is
like an honorary crib he all he does is
hang with the Christmas
I mean he went to Adam's wedding yeah so
uh he's always been cool with dub and
the people that dub break around and the
fact that me and Doug have like a great
relationship that's how we even got
closer than what we you know I'm saying
when we first met whatever it was so
uh when I came home I came I did the
interview I could pop back up I did an
interview then I started like being on
YouTube but I didn't really understand
so I started reaching out like hey I do
he like you should come on yeah like and
we'd start going into
hey I feel like I'm ready to I mean hop
on camera like [__] well you guys
already having those conversations prior
to 80 leaving yeah he was already I was
already damn near
he was there like multiple times when I
was coming up there like for like news
and different little [__] like that so I
didn't even see because I don't go home
like this [__] tires you out sometimes
to where I don't go home and watch the
[__] we were doing yeah
and then I go back and and go watch it
you get what I'm saying so even if like
I just seen 80 Adam so when I was seeing
the the headlines and all that [__] like
somebody leaving or whatever I'm like
yeah
yeah I don't really want to get into the
[__] that's going on right you know what
I mean the mess because it's like gossip
you know what I'm saying because if it's
not coming to my phone directly I'm not
really so I'm like I was paying no
attention to it then when it started
being everywhere I'm like oh wait that
ain't no click bait type [__] you get
what I'm saying like if that's how slow
I am when I'm first coming in I'm like I
don't know I'm thinking they trying to
get the numbers up or something so now
I'm seeing Oh it's blushing this that
and I'm like oh
it's going down in this [__]
like I'm texting Gina Gina trying to
hold it stand her ground and then she go
that was a wild that was a extremely
wild
um
extremely Wild
couple of days because I got a
hit up by Adam to come and fill in for
Lush or fill in for whoever
not knowing that he had just fired Lush
and
so I called ad and I know Adam called me
and told me what happened with Lesh and
he was like I need somebody tomorrow to
be on the show so I called A.D and I was
like yo
uh what's the deal you know like
he's like yo do it tomorrow
oh [__] yeah cause I I didn't talk to
A.D about it but I already know what his
response was going to be to me because
we already was there so right and then
what do I I don't have a job y'all
leaving with like I'm just getting you
everybody's like oh you stayed or you
was with no jumper after that so what
who was offering me a spot where they at
where who did I leave from yeah you were
already I'm not a part of that crew that
makes sense I was gonna say uh recently
you guys interviewed the gay [__] guy
which uh was extremely interesting
to say the least I just like sharp just
in the corner just like what the [__]
happening not sharply hey Chris said
some [__] where he was like you know DP
would he educated the dude who what a DP
was he's like not getting your whole
[__] blown out by a bunch of n-words
but I was gonna say like when you do an
interview like that do you hear about
that from like your like big homies like
yo what are you doing yeah they but no
all right so the big Hobbies was mad but
they thought I was stamping
homie yeah the whole time I'm like
letting him get his [__] off and telling
him like
nah we ain't going for that well he also
clearly is in a [__] yeah he's remover
or whatever he's doing this and like how
are you a gang member you don't know
what a DP is that's what I'm saying it
is it's like you guys were educating him
yeah that's what I'm telling I'm like
the lack of knowledge like bro you don't
know what that is that you said that you
from so that's why I told him that like
all throughout the interview then at the
end I really taught him like
they gotta watch it man they gotta watch
it because the whole interview ain't now
he keep on serving ClickBank I mean uh
clip after clip you know you know what
he does but once the whole interview
drops oh interview Drive you'll see
what's going on I'm definitely not
stamping no gay [__] and he's from over
we don't really like yeah I mean like
I'm not gonna keep on saying that
because but no but but at the same time
I can't even in politics why I can't eat
politic on him I can't give him a DP
beat him up or nothing because he's not
just a crazy movie that goes yeah I mean
that [__] crazy they got a deal I just
saw the clip and it was so funny uh
shout out to [__] Mack who's one of the
most widely entertained human beings
that's ever watched the face of this
earth
oh God damn well listen man uh
you got are you doing a weekly stream
now yeah so I'll do it a weekly straight
Break by break man uh this week we we
doing jail videos okay
you already know we going into chirag
rare we going into all type of [__] so
what's the go-to spread for you if you
had to make a spread right now out of
jail what are you putting in the spread
uh
uh noodles or no noodles noodles with
noodles all right so I'm going uh Thai
Noodle with I got two packs of Thai
noodles with with a pack of chicken
noodles right bust them in half so they
still get stringy uh
two packs of squeezed cheese uh
um a half of a
jalapenos squeeze cheese uh
like a
damn type of bar is that a pepper jack
cheese bar half of that melted down
with the uh cheese puffs you gotta put
the cheese puss in the cheese too okay
and uh some people put cheeses I don't
[__] with the cheeses in there bro so
gotta shake that up make the sauce
that's cut up the chicken warm it up you
gotta saying season the chicken
put the little bit of the thai sauce in
there
put it all together that's the Alfredo
in jail man oh chicken alfredo that
sounds fire I could do it with the uh
mackerel too you know what I'm saying I
love it with the fish sometimes so uh
weekly stream you're obviously on no
jumper how many times a week now two or
three sometimes more man has been going
on it's been going up right so I'm there
I'm in there
um yo how do you feel about the gun
situation since you have an EP with them
that's it because he's obviously your
boy that's what I'm saying that's my boy
like and he's going up right now [__]
you mean is everywhere so the whole [__]
is this right I like like I said Till
him and slime get over that differences
because I've known Jeff for longer yeah
I mean I I stand where I stand and I
[__] with him that's that's that's my
bro but like dropping music and all that
they will have to definitely come to
something to where it don't look like
I'm choosing sides with somebody that
did my little bro wrong and I've known
him for longer you get what I'm saying
but he ain't
this is my boy still you know that's why
I'm telling everybody because the [__]
that he did for me when I needed him
yeah gonna the the stuff that he did for
me when I needed him and
yeah I mean this [__] that [__]
I grew up with wouldn't have done they
never did so it's like and it and it's
not even
it's the smallest [__] I'm talking about
not the obvious like okay see he was up
when I came home yeah but like just the
small [__] even from checking in when I
first left to do you have any just
little [__] that yeah I mean so a
[__] always is here for you for
advice and we can always go because it's
just like your cousin that thought like
we can't even go out and do all that no
Street [__] yeah I mean but like as far
as but and I don't like taking a plea
ain't telling right first and foremost
so it's not telling I think I actually
think a lot of it is like like the
outrage should be like if they're
because he's just doing what like a lot
everyone else did right yeah but then
because then they don't give a [__]
nobody everybody else it's the narrative
bro it's the narrative and we don't know
how young thug feels about it even slime
like shotty he's his career has been
over with since then too because if you
think about it I mean gonna came back
but we don't know how thug thug feels
about any of this I mean he saw I at the
end of the day the bigger gun is the
better it is he's still YSL on the label
so
but listen to what I've tried to tell
you right
he didn't tell he took a plea
the [__] that he said yes to was obvious
why is Shelby at the street gang
everybody in the city know that whatever
but the only way that that was cool was
if everybody was in agreeance of you
taking your deal at that time because if
everybody could have got that deal
and even Thug one one year time served
the rest of probation 10-year probation
I feel like everybody would have just
copped in like all right well I'm
offering everybody on this deal this hey
y'all do this y'all gonna be on
probation for 10 years I feel like the
whole case would have took that took
that right you get what I'm saying but
you can't do that and then have some
people still going to trial and that's
exactly and you're out fighting against
it and the perception of that is bad
yeah it's like you got to kind of stay
down with them in in La like
you get a violation for that like you
damn near not from the hood no more but
geez you get what I'm saying like so
it's just different like but
he don't if he don't have to sit on the
stand and all that they take all that
into consideration too that it was just
a plea deal what he what he's trying to
get across to everybody else like it's
just a pleading that guy copped out on
some [__] that we're that we fighting
against though so it's like it said
different it does I mean listen man
we'll see what happens but look you're
killing it uh go follow him I hope you
put out some music man because I feel
like I feel that we gonna be back with
the music uh we gonna do something I
told him I was gonna freestyle today but
I'm hungry to the [__] yeah so
uh we definitely gonna get back together
my guy brick baby I appreciate you
brother boom my God yeah he does love
baby hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hard Dean
don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Harding in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine